ein steuerloch mit vielen nullen wegen
der korona krise werden bund ländern und
kommunen fast 100 milliarden euro fehlen
sagen die steuerschätzer das virus und
die kinder weltweit berichten ärzte von
schweren entzündungen bei ganz jungen
cupid 19 patienten forscher prüfen einen
zusammenhang und einen neustart mit
fragezeichen die deutsche fußball-liga
ringt um klare regeln für eine unklare
saison
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend in allen
zum blick in die welt an diesem
donnerstag
das ist wegen corona schlimm wird für
die staatsfinanzen war vorauszusehen wie
schlimm
davon haben wir seit heute eine etwas
bessere ahnung denn heute gab es die
prognose der steuerschätzer
und die sieht so aus bund länder und
kommunen werden in diesem jahr fast 100
milliarden euro weniger einnehmen als
zuletzt vorhergesagt ein gigantisches
steuerloch noch größer als in der
finanzkrise 2009 und das in einer zeit
in der der staat für corona hilfen
etliche milliarden mehr ausgeben muss
cornelia schiemenz es sind bittere
wahrheiten die olaf scholz da heute
verkünden muss nur halb ironisch daher
seine ersten worte willkommen
eine normalität in der riesige
schuldenberge auf die deutschen zu
kommen weil steuereinnahmen wegbrechen
und maßnahmen zur corona bekämpfung
immense geldsummen kosten nur eine
momentaufnahme und der weitere verlauf
der pandemie kann ja nicht wirklich
seriös vorhergesagt werden
das ist eine naturkatastrophe mit der
wir konfrontiert sind
die korona krise stürzt deutschland in
die voraussichtlich schwerste rezession
der nachkriegszeit die regierung will
anfang juni mit einem konjunkturpaket
gegensteuern
über dessen höhe schweigt sich der
finanzminister noch aus hohe
investitionen in unser land in den
sozialen zusammenhalt und eine moderne
und klimafreundliche zukunft bleiben da
unsere richtschnur
wie umgehen mit diesen immensen steuer
verlosten sparen oder investieren
der politische wettlauf hat gerade
begonnen als der fc immer gesagt hat
unabhängig von corona dass bei uns eine
menge sachen richtung eu ropa
europäische ausgaben richtung
flüchtlings ausgaben oder auch
diverse zwei religion religions- themen
nicht mehr leisten können auch so was
wie abwrackprämien oder die e auto
prämie beispielsweise kosten verdammt
viel geld führen aber nicht dazu dass
die wirtschaft nachhaltig in deutschland
gestärkt wird und noch eine debatte wird
geführt werden müssen die um
steuererhöhungen
wir als linke fordern in dieser
situation eine vermögensabgabe auf sehr
sehr große vermögen
ich halte von derzeitigen
steuererhöhungsdebatte überhaupt nichts
wir müssen jetzt die unternehmen retten
wir müssen jetzt die sohle selbständigen
unterstützen wir müssen jetzt dafür
sorgen dass das kurzarbeitergeld
ausreichend bezahlt wird die zeit der
schwarzen null ist geschichte olaf
scholz wird in den kommenden monaten
harte kämpfe führen müssen
und was heißt das jetzt für projekte der
regierung da ist zunächst mal ein alter
streit innerhalb der koalition wieder
voll aufgebrochen um die frage nämlich
wie sinnvoll ist die grundrente die
grundrente wird morgen zum ersten mal im
bundestag beraten in kraft treten soll
sie eigentlich 2021 und allen zu gute
kommen die viele jahre in die
rentenkasse eingezahlt haben und dann
auch nur eine niedrige rente bekommen
andreas huppert und mathis feldhoff
jetzt mit mehr
morgen soll eigentlich sein projekt im
bundestag auf den weg gebracht werden
die grundrente von sozialminister
hubertus heil
doch kurz vor der ersten lesung des
gesetzes kracht es gewaltig in der
koalition wegen der bisher fehlenden
finanzierung droht die grundrente zu
scheitern
da muss der bundesfinanzminister nun
endlich mal die werden norddeutschland
sagen in die puschen kommen und dass
auch erledigen was er zugesagt hat er
wollte eine europäische
finanztransaktionssteuer die hat er
bislang noch nicht vorweisen können
im letzten jahr hatte sich die koalition
auf höchster ebene darauf verständigt
grundrente ja aber nur wenn das geld
nicht aus dem allgemeinen haushalt kommt
die spd hatte zugesagt die nötigen 1,3
milliarden euro bei aktien spekulanten
einzusammeln
davon will sie jetzt abweichen
das geld kommt aus dem steuersäckel und
die der vorschlag den der finanz besser
gemacht hat ist eine europäische
finanztransaktionssteuer
und wenn dies nicht gelingen sollte für
uns weder den nationalen wir werden eine
lösung finden angesichts der korona
hilfen ist für die spd eine milliarde
mehr
auch noch drin die union für die die
grundrente nie herzensangelegenheit war
dagegen gibt vor auf jeden cent zu
achten
an diesen fraktion sicav droht jetzt
sein projekt zu scheitern der minister
man zur einigung das haben sich menschen
verdient das haben wir in der koalition
besprochen das hat die bundesregierung
beschlossen
und ich glaube die bürgerinnen und
bürger erwarten von uns das wird auch
liefern
neuer krach in der großen koalition die
unendliche geschichte der grundrente
geht weiter und auch heute abend holen
wir theo koll mit dazu genannt theo
morgen dann wie gehört
auseinandersetzung im bundestag
grundrente wie schaaf wird denn der
kraft dazu noch und wieder werden nun
der krach wird denn der ist schon sehr
sehr ernst beide seiten spd und union
haben das gefühl dass der jeweils andere
im begriff ist sein gegebenes wort zu
brechen
die union besteht darauf dass die spd
die zugesagte finanzierung und die
bedarfsprüfung einhält beides sieht sie
als nicht gewährleistet an die
versprochene europäische
finanztransaktionssteuer sei in weiter
ferne und eine art prinzip hoffnung
reicht ihr nicht aus sagt die
unionsfraktion
die spd wiederum fühlt sich betrogen
weil man sich nach monatelangen
verhandlungen geeinigt habe es gebe
einen kabinettsbeschluss zur grundrente
und im vergleich zu den vielen
milliarden für die korona schäden sei
die grundrente ein eher kleiner betrag
also wenn sich an diesen beidseitigen
betrugs gefühl nichts ändert dann wird
die grundrente auf eine sehr lange
parlamentarische bank geschoben werden
und dann gucken meint er und auch für
moment auf das ganz große bild jahre
lang war die schwarze null das ziel
und jetzt so ein steuerloch wie
dramatisch ist dieses - für den staat
das war interessant wer heute den
bundesfinanzminister erlebt hat bei der
verkündung der steuerschätzung der
konnte das gefühl gewinnen
die zahlen sind zwar dramatisch aber die
lager eigentlich nicht es ist sicher
auch dem sehr unaufgeregten naturell von
olaf scholz geschuldet aber er meinte
wörtlich wir können uns das was wir uns
vorgenommen haben weiterhin leisten
scholz will statt zu sparen geld
ausgeben gegen die krise das problem ist
dass gleichzeitig aus dem steuertopf so
viel wie noch nie entnommen wird für
alle möglichen hilfsprogramme
andererseits aber auch so wenig
reinkommt wie bisher nicht für möglich
gehalten am ende dürften wir eine
staatsverschuldung haben die für
deutsche verhältnisse dramatisch hoch
ist mit der aber andere staaten auch
schon seit jahren leben verdammt vielen
dank und die entwicklung bei den steuern
die schlägt natürlich auch voll durch
auf die finanzen in den städten und
gemeinden
was das konkret heißt für uns alle zeigt
jetzt tadeusz parade am beispiel köln
eigentlich war köln auf einem richtig
guten weg die schulden der vergangenheit
weitgehend getilgt ein ausgeglichener
haushalt in sicht mit der heutigen
steuerschätzung aber ist klar alles
umsonst corona ist ein gewaltiges loch
in die stadtkasse köln wird das viel
geld kosten fast zehn prozent unseres
jährlichen 5 milliarden haushalts das
werden zwischen 450 und 500 millionen
sein
neben massiven steuereinbrüchen fehlen
auch die einnahmen zum beispiel aus
öffentlichen verkehrsbetrieben museen
oder theater alle ausgaben auf den
prüfstand so lautet deshalb die
anweisungen der stadtspitze noch viel
spielraum gibt es nicht köln rechnet man
auch mit einem rasanten anstieg der
sozialleistungen in fast allen städten
der republik wird jetzt gerechnet und
jedes bundesland verfolgt eigene
konzepte um seinen kommunen zu helfen
die landesregierung in
nordrhein-westfalen stellt neben
soforthilfen zum beispiel langfristige
kredite in aussicht zehn milliarden neue
garantien für kommunen liquidität wird
zur verfügung gestellt und kommunale
unternehmen bekommen den zugang zu
hilfspaketen den sie bisher nicht noch
mehr kredite noch mehr schulden zu
lasten der kommunen
nicht der richtige weg sagen kritiker
ein gemeinsamer rettungsschirm von bund
und ländern müsse her fordern kommunal
interessenverbände wir werden ein
riesendefizit haben und das geht bis zur
handlungsunfähigkeit wenn bund und
länder nicht den notwendigen
rettungsschirm als baldauf sparen die
zeit drängt bis zu 60 milliarden euro an
einnahmeausfällen müssten kommunen
dieses und kommendes jahr im schlimmsten
fall verkraften und wie sind die folgen
der krise abzumildern dazu hat der
bundestag heute folgende hilfen
beschlossen
und die können wir jetzt mal durchgehen
wichtig für die inzwischen rund zehn
millionen menschen in kurzarbeit nach
vier monaten sollen sie künftig 70
prozent des früheren nettolohnes
bekommen nach sieben monaten 80 prozent
und wer kinder hat bekommt jeweils
sieben prozent mehr
dann für alle in der altenpflege sie
sollen für ihre erschwerte arbeit bis zu
1000 euro prämie bekommen und künftig
kann sich jeder von uns auf corona
testen lassen auch ohne symptome
das bezahlt die krankenkasse und das
wird kosten christiane hübscher
berichtet bezahltes testen auf corona
für alle das geht jetzt weil die labore
inzwischen die kapazität haben für
deutschlandweit eine million tests
wöchentlich tatsächlich gemacht wurden
in der letzten woche aber nur 382.000
der bundesgesundheitsminister will nun
großflächig vor allem risikogruppen
testen lassen
wie weit noch weiter die möglichkeit aus
auch zulasten der krankenversicherung zu
testen in pflegeeinrichtungen in
krankenhäusern es beginnt die phase des
strategischen testens in alters und
pflegeheimen wo es zuletzt größere
ausbrüche gegeben hatte genau wie in
krankenhäusern sollen jetzt regelmäßig
alle getestet werden um schlummernde
infektionsherde früh zu erkennen
wir halten es für notwendig dass jeder
patient war geplant ins krankenhaus
aufgenommen wird getestet wird und
genauso wichtig ist dass wir die
mitarbeiter zumindest diejenigen die eng
am patienten arbeiten in maschen testen
ein test kostet etwa 60 euro für die
krankenkassen werden das schnell viele
millionen euro pro woche
die protestieren vor allem gegen die
kostenübernahme von anlasslosen tests
für jedermann
es ist notwendig dass es in einem
zweiten schritt dort eine rückzahlung
aus dem staatshaushalt gibt da ist
bisher die aussage von herrn minister
sparen und aus der bundesregierung noch
zu vage
denn sparen will über einen
bundeszuschuss mit den kassen erst im
herbst reden dabei schmelzen die
rücklagen der krankenversicherungen mit
jedem tag
egal wie ein crooner test ausfällt ab
jetzt müssen alle ergebnisse gemeldet
werden
und hier kommen die gesundheitsämter ins
spiel für sie stellt der bund 50
millionen euro zur verfügung damit die
wichtige daten auswerten können wann
gilt wer als geheilt wo haben sich
infizierte wahrscheinlich angesteckt
viel arbeit für die ämter zb in marburg
wie in klinge berichtet hunderte
telefonate jeden tag im callcenter des
gesundheitsamts in marburg unterstützen
studentinnen anders wäre die mühsame
suche nach kontaktpersonen von corona
patienten gar nicht zu schaffen
manche erkrankte hat sieht 150 anrufe
nach sich wir müssen jede einzelne
kontaktperson abfragen darf telefon
persönlich sprechen und abschätzen
detailliert wie war der kontakt haben
sie ein hohes risiko ein geringes risiko
sich anzustecken müssen die auch in
absonderungen können die weiter arbeiten
zum beispiel sehr aufwendig
wer symptome hat wird zum test geschickt
noch klappt das hier in marburg wochen
lang hat sich das gesamte gesundheitsamt
nur um corona gekümmert
doch die aktuellen lockerungen
betrachtet die stellvertretende leiterin
des amts mit großer sorge ebenso die
neue regel dass es erst bei 50
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner in
einer woche wieder beschränkungen geben
soll so wirklich 50 fälle pro 100.000
einwohner
in einer woche haben würde das für
unseren landkreis über 120 positive
personen bedeuten das wäre sehr sehr
viel und mit der jetzigen personal
situation sicherlich nicht zu schaffen
das gesundheitsamt marburg beobachtet
daher sehr genau wie sich die fallzahlen
entwickeln und appelliert an die
vernunft aller die hygieneregeln zu
beachten und abstand zu halten
und dann gucken wir jetzt auf die
aktuellen zahlen da zeigt sich bei den
neuinfektionen weiter ein positiver
trend nach unten
durchschnittlich auf eine woche
betrachtet haben sich jeden tag 850
menschen neu angesteckt das ist der
niedrigste wert seit wochen
insgesamt sind stand vor einer halben
stunde mehr als 174.000 infektionen
durch tests bestätigt davon sind gut
150.000 betroffene wieder genesen und
7861 menschen starben in verbindung mit
das sind die reinen zahlen wie der
körper auf das virus reagiert darüber
ist längst noch nicht alles bekannt
bei kindern zum beispiel ist der verlauf
einer infektion in vielen fällen eher
mild aber aus aller welt gibt es
berichte dass es bei kindern schwere
entzündungen gibt weil ihr immunsystem
überreagiert ich glaube wir müssen damit
rechnen dass wir am anfang dieser großen
pandemien immer noch stehen und dass wir
damit auch mehr erkrankungen bei kindern
haben werden definitiv und damit wird es
auch mehr komplikationsrate verläufe
geben auch in deutschland sagt professor
bernhard und das phänomen könnte
tatsächlich mit 19 in verbindung stehen
unser korrespondent johannes hano
berichtet aus new york ein
statt in der mittlerweile 100 kinder
diese mysteriöse krankheit haben polizei
und rettungskräfte klatschen als der
achtjährige gegen hannover wieder gesund
aus dem krankenhaus entlassen wird groß
die erleichterung denn es sah nicht gut
aus
alles hat mit einem herzinfarkt im bett
begonnen dann kamen die rettungskräfte
mehr als 100 kinder sind in new york dem
epizentrum der korona pandemie in den
vergangenen drei wochen einer krankheit
mit mysteriösen verlauf erkrankt es
beginnt mit fieber und bauchschmerzen
bei schweren verläufen kann es tödlich
enden
new yorks gouverneur spricht eine
warnung aus wir haben drei kinder
verloren 1 5 von einem sieben jahre
alten jungen und ein 18 jähriges mädchen
das ist eine sehr verstörende situation
ich weiß dass eltern in new york mit dem
ganzen land beunruhigt sind und sie
sollten es auch sagt viele symptome
ähneln der sogenannten kawasaki
krankheit aber die sei es nicht da sind
sich die ärzte hier new york ziemlich
sicher die erkrankung müsse mit dem
corona virus zusammenhängen
fast alle kinder hätten korrekt
antikörper oder seien positiv getestet
wir denken dass es ein phänomen ist dass
nach einer kurve infektion auftaucht die
patienten die infiziert waren bilden
antikörper einige von ihnen entwickeln
eine normale aggressive reaktion des
immunsystems dass diese krankheit bei
kindern jetzt praktisch aus dem nichts
auftaucht macht den ärzten hier große
sorge zeige es doch dass man noch lange
nicht verstanden hat wie das virus
funktioniert wie gefährlich es ist meine
kinder mit hohem fieber und magen
probleme sollten eltern nicht lange
zögern und sofort zum arzt gehen beiden
wäre es fast zu spät gewesen
was macht das kona virus mit kindern
dazu gibt es mehr in unserer zdf heute
und jetzt weitere wichtige nachrichten
heute bereits seit jahren bringt ungarn
asylbewerber in lagern an der grenze zu
serbien unter darüber hat heute das
höchste eu gericht entschieden und nach
ansicht des europäischen gerichtshofs
verstößt es gegen eu-recht die
flüchtlinge im lager roeske
einzelfallprüfung festzuhalten die
bedingungen in der transitzone glichen
einer inhaftierung die flüchtlinge
werden lange festgehalten und haben
keine bewegungsfreiheit
die vier kläger dürfen nun ein neues
asylverfahren beantragen ein soldat der
eliteeinheit kommando spezialkräfte hat
zuhause waffen gehortet er sitzt jetzt
in untersuchungshaft
auf dem privatgelände des mannes in kolm
in sachsen hatte die polizei gestern
neben waffen auch munition und
sprengstoff sichergestellt
heute gegen die durchsuchung weiter der
militärische abschirmdienst hatte den
soldaten schon länger im visier
zuletzt waren häufiger extremistische
verdachtsfälle in der bundeswehr ans
licht gekommen rolf hochhuth ist tote
einer der wichtigsten und auch
umstrittensten deutschen dramatiker der
nachkriegszeit thema seiner werke immer
wieder der nationalsozialismus
theatergeschichte schrieb nutzer 63 mit
dem vatikan drama der stellvertreter das
stück gab dem papst eine mitschuld am
holocaust ein skandal der zum welterfolg
wohnen auch danach mischte er sich ein
eckte an und dieser kampfeslust blieb er
bis ins hohe alter treu rolf hochhuth
wurde 89 jahre alt was ganz anderes
jetzt der kommende samstag ist für
fußballfans ein wichtiger tag es wird
nämlich wieder gespielt in der
bundesliga ein paar fragen rund um diese
besonderen partien mussten allerdings
noch geklärt werden heute etwa die wie
viele spieler ausgewechselt werden
dürfen und die frage wie lange die
spielzeit überhaupt dauert was aber
passiert wenn die saison doch
abgebrochen werden müsste
darauf gab es heute noch keine antwort
peter leissl entscheidend ist auf dem
platz dieser alte fußballweisheit wird
erst am wochenende in den vordergrund
rücken
zugegeben ohne die mitreißende
atmosphäre drumherum
die deutsche fußball liga und ihr
geschäftsführer christian seifert
wollten offenbar zu schnell zu viel
ihr vorstoß ein szenario von allen
proficlubs heute verabschieden zu lassen
aufgeschoben
ein abbruch der jederzeit gewertet
werden würde mit einem meister zwei
absteigern zwei aufsteigern aus der
zweiten liga aber keine relegation
das soll bei knapp der
hälfte der vereine widerspruch erzeugt
haben erst in vorwiegend clubs in
unteren tabellenregionen zum beispiel
werder bremen das befürchten muss zum
ersten mal seit 40 jahren wieder
abzusteigen oder dynamo dresden
besonders hart getroffen durch eine
zweiwöchige zwangscharakter momentan
eine rechtliche anfechtungen wie in der
französischen und niederländischen liga
will man unbedingt vermeiden
so wurden zunächst nur folgende punkte
verabschiedet es werden fünf
auswechslungen erlaubt sein neutraler
ersatzspielort können im notfall
festgelegt werden und ein saisonende
wäre auch noch im juli denkbar
ungezügelter jubel wie beim hinspiel in
freiburg in leipzig am samstag und
denkbar die hygiene regeln verlangen
eine neue choreografie ob das jetzt
ausgefallen wenn du nicht weil sie nicht
wichtig ist dass man erst mal ein tor
schießen dann können wir uns einfach
überlegen wie man eben frust bleibt man
sowieso lieber allein so und zum schluss
bei uns noch das 40 jahre lang haben die
beiden türme des atomkraftwerks in
philippsburg die region in nordbaden
geprägt keine minute hatte es heute
gedauert da waren die geschichte heute
morgen 6 5 zwei explosionen und die rund
150 meter hohen türme fielen in sich
zusammen
bilder die man auch ein paar mal
hintereinander gucken kann aus immer
neuen blickwinkeln
was kommt jetzt keine grüne wiese der
betreiber baut dort jetzt ein
umspannwerk guckt mir aufs wetter ab dem
wochenende wird zwar wärmer aber in der
kommenden nacht gibt es örtlich wieder
frost mehr hat gleich besten telli ich
empfehle ihnen das heute journal mit der
kollegin marietta slomka um 21 uhr 45
von uns allen danke für ihr großes
interesse gerne bis morgen in ein
angenehm haben
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter unser wetter
bestimmendes hoch rutscht allmählich
richtung süden und lenkt in den nächsten
tagen deutlich wärmere luft aus
westlichen richtungen direkt nach
deutschland
wir schauen erst mal in die nacht und da
gibt es im norden einzelne schauer im
süden ist es dichter bewölkt vor allem
südlich der donau oder regnet es sonst
klart es auf und dort wo die wolken
fehlen wird am kältesten temperaturen
bis minus zwei grad in der norddeutschen
tiefebene und 9 grad im südwesten
deutschlands dort hits am mildesten sein
im norden deutschlands morgen im
tagesverlauf einzelne schauer aber
relativ viele wolken noch mehr wolken
dann südlich der donau die bleiben dort
und es regnet weiter ansonsten gibt es
sonnige abschnitte vor allem nach westen
hin temperaturen erreichen dabei acht
grad im süden und 18 grad im
rhein-main-gebiet die nächsten tage am
samstag im süden und norden letzte
schauer sonst freundlicher bis 20 grad
und ab sonntag wird es deutlich härter
wärmer bis 25 grad am montag damit ein
schöner abend